I'm Adrenalina Kassadin see dodgy [ __ ]
in Paris Castle pre-marriage about
premier el combustible rencontre play
its Molitor
[Music]
I know man right so the cows ten
Cuarenta honest
Oh mio problem Arizona VA - so Chivas
adage you have is on 15 much flag kind
of a yugioh bgallagh tautology
[Music]
Giovanna parklands eh oh god poor con
Quattro's occasionally mughal-e-azam a
on display see Rocco Covanta gentle yoga
dr. J zero division a bowling team gives
presents oriented person the book of
Esther pay Giovanna g-g-gee personage
Cost Estimator it chemical and food was
plentiful in freedom search messages
delete the sighing registry trade our
via day we will barely be the possible
messages of all the stress for max we
don't crescendo with senators about
Alegria
was some decision that once pesos
default arsenide trabajar I meant for
tatra baile de Alta suspect achievers
were two songs photos knowledge matters
vegetarian conclusion to the travail to
the football
you
when I first started climbing I was so
bad I was so terrible so slow and tear
my skin up all the time it was like how
the heck are we gonna go and do Mount
Kilimanjaro
three words I don't know those three
words three of the most important words
in my life
all discoveries happen from I don't know
my name is Kyle Maynard and I have an
extremely hard time saying what it is
exactly that I do
I've been an athlete my entire life
football - wrestling - weightlifting and
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and now most
recently taking on climbing some of the
highest mountains in the world
I was born with congenital amputation so
it basically means my arms and that the
elbow is my legs end at the knees you
know I think some people who they look
at me and maybe even feel sorry for me
but really truthfully my life doesn't
look a whole lot different than yours
you know I type on my computer the same
way you know use my phone just like
anybody else I'm on bumble like anybody
any other single person my age we got a
match my first experience with climbing
really anything of significance was in a
CrossFit competition in 2010 the first
workout was he had to do a
thousand-meter rowing machine in a
sprint up Stone Mountain everybody else
did it maybe 25 minutes it took me an
hour and 46 minutes at Arles getting up
on my arms but I got to the top and I
was like wow this is breathtakingly
beautiful then I told my friend that
night I said I want to climb Mount
Kilimanjaro I don't know if I can I
don't know if I can't but I do know that
I want to try to figure it out I want to
go and find a way and get up there
there were a ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear I literally started
with bath towels duct-taped on my arms
to my feet I couldn't go to the store
and buy a typical pair of shoes so we
had to come up with a unique solution
now to climb I use a carbon fiber
special custom shoe
and use those to bear crawl up
Kilimanjaro then me and my team we took
on climbing Mount Aconcagua the highest
peak in South America I felt my body was
like in full shutdown mode
and it was brutal at moments but it was
breathtakingly beautiful at the top of
that mountain you know you can almost
kind of make out and see like the
curvature of the earth I mean it was
just a moment I'll never forget the
reasons I climb aren't that different
from other people 95% of it does suck
I'm staring at the dirt I'm not even
able to go and talk to my friends and
see the beautiful views unless I stop
and sit down and look but that 5% that
doesn't suck it's amazing
get in a place that there's no way my
wheelchair could have brought me there
that's what I love I'm not trying to
live to be a thousand like I want to I
want to go out there and have my life
means something when I've gotten down
and I've looked at the mountain and I
see what we've achieved it's like wow
maybe that was a really bad idea that we
were there but it was beautiful
[Music]
kind of like a skater has a skateboarder
BMX air has a bike I just saw the
wheelchairs something fun so why not
take it into the park I'm Erin wheels
fathering him and I ride w CM x w CM X
stands for wheelchair motocross it's you
know taking your chair into the skate
park and hitting ramps kinda the same
thing as BMX but with a wheelchair I
first started going to the skate parks
when I was eight years old and I've been
doing it for 16 years now the wheelchair
is definitely just an extension of my
body because skaters aren't always on
their skateboard and bikers aren't
always on the bike but I'm always on my
chair so that gives me like an unfair
advantage to just practice everywhere I
go I feel like I'm lucky but I always
have my wheelchair with me because I can
just jump whenever I want I was born
with spina bifida I've had 21 surgeries
throughout my life and I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals and yeah it would
be easy to just be bummed out on that
but I was for me I just found the
positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time in 2008
I got the Guinness world record for the
first backflip on a wheelchair now is
that a local competition here in Vegas
called am Jim
that was a pretty cool day one of my
favorite tricks is just simple hand flip
because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up and you know
watching the pros do it it just was
something I wanted to learn I'm very
blessed to be able to do what I love
what I'm passionate about for a living a
lot of the time the wheelchair comes
with the stereotype of you can't do this
or whatever because it's a medical
device
I just always seen the wheelchair is a
great opportunity
the first thing I googled was how to
teach a guy without arms to shoot a bow
and there's nothing out there like that
because it's such a rare thing
my name is Matt Sussman I'm from careful
Iowa and I'm a professional Archer
that's how there you go in 1982 I was
born as you see me right now without in
the arms I never see not having arms as
a limitation it's amazing how your body
when it's missing something your other
limbs take off and kind of pick up the
slack so for me my feet are my hands
everything that I have in my life I do
with my toes it's pretty rare that I
don't use my feet for something my phone
for example how I pick up my phone I'd
actually grab it with my foot and flip
it and catch it and be like hello when I
got started shooting it took me about
two weeks from looking at a bow till
shooting probably my first arrow because
I had to figure out how to pull it with
this toe or this toe or this foot or
that foot I had to kind of think outside
the box and come up with some creative
ways of shooting I actually hold the
bell with my right foot but I will
pretend it's somebody's right arm in my
mind and then I have a release say that
goes over my right shoulder and I
actually hooked that onto the string and
when I sit up I push my foot away from
my chest which draws the bow at this
point I'm aiming I don't see a guy
without arms shooting I see somebody
with arm shooting and I guess it's just
how I imagined it I did repetitions i
sat in a chair for eight hours a day six
days a week time kind of slows way down
you forget who's around you you forget
what you're doing almost and you're so
focused on one thing shot and shot and
shot and shot and shot that's all I did
this bow right here has a million arrows
shot through it at the end of the day
you know helps you become good a couple
medals or trophies that stand out to me
is my Paralympic silver medal I also had
the Guinness world record for the
longest accurate archery shot and I shot
an arrow and hit a target from 310
I want my kids to see that no matter
what the challenge is you can overcome
it
you just have to put your head down and
push through and figure out a way to be
successful figure out a way to just you
know be a good person while you do all
that stuff at the end of the day I just
want to be the best in the world I don't
care if you have arms you don't have
arms I don't care if you were the
Michael Jordan of the sport and you are
enabled by the archer I just want to
beat you because I want to be known as
the best archer in the world pull your
shoulder blades back together there you
go Bible and doing it excited at the gym
is really keeping me alive okay three
more yeah correct if I want to start
working out at the gym I love how you
did by now okay my name is Wayne McCray
Washington and I'm a professional
bodybuilder yeah I know you can see from
my hand moving
oh we diagnosed with throat palsy a year
11 months
you know I got off with scoliosis at the
age of 12
when I first went to doctor they had
told me that I was not gonna live to 15
years old
weight and I have been friends here at
the gym I'm his personal trainer yes and
he approached me with a very serious
tone and he told me that he wants to do
a bodybuilding show you know one of my
goals work nearby really the other one
would be a perfect a wrestler with the
wrestling with two dangers in the
beginning he didn't have the control to
get on a machine and just work the body
parts that we were intending to work his
hands and his feet need to be stabilized
you in yeah all right so I got very
creative and I built up you know
apparatuses that would fit him in order
for him to secure himself and actually
pull with the muscles that I was wanting
him to do
you can stead of it telling me what to
do you're telling we have when to do you
so let's tell it what to do again okay
okay the way I approach everything every
time I train I had to focus a lot harder
and a lot more on wood firing [ __ ] that
won't work at all to make it work right
for me it has improved a lot
the basic happiness that comes from
feeling strong and feeling able instead
of disabled is a big deal Mumbai has got
a lot straighter
I hope people tell me their own taller
um every day is still well but it's
called seeing Wade accomplish his pro
status as a bodybuilder was the most
unbelievable experience this was
something no one ever thought could
happen and it happened we made this
happen if it's amazing
and I'm blessed to have a coach 19 or
friend latina
I enjoy being a pro bodybuilder it's my
lifestyle now
you
you